[Musica]
buonasera e io vorrei partire dal fatto
che viviamo in un mondo iperconnesso e
grazie all'avvento di internet e alle
nuove tecnologie siamo in grado di
comunicare con persone in ogni parte del
mondo e grazie ai social network
possiamo comunicare senza alcun tipo di
barriere nei temporali e spaziali e
quello che abbiamo osservato negli
ultimi anni è un vero e proprio cambio
di paradigma
siamo passati dal vecchio contesto
quello rappresentato dai media
tradizionali la televisione la radio la
stampa in cui l'informazione prima di
giungere al pubblico veniva in qualche
modo mediata dagli esperti del settore
dai giornalisti dagli editori il nuovo
contesto quello in tutti noi ci muoviamo
attualmente invece fortemente
disintermediato chiunque può andare
online e non solo accedere ad una
vastità di contenuti ma soprattutto
contribuire a crearne di nuovi e non c'è
di nuovo solo la disintermediazione ma
proprio la struttura di questo nuovo
spazio informativo in cui ci muoviamo
che è caratterizzato da una presenza
continua e costante di nuovi contenuti
in cui spesso possiamo anche perdere i
nostri punti di riferimento e i tempi
sono sempre più corti sono quasi
annullati quindi in un contesto di
questo tipo le nostre capacità di
analisi di riflessione sono duramente
messe alla prova e meccanismi cognitivi
di cui ci serviamo tutti noi
abitualmente nella nostra vita
quotidiana
quindi si tratta di scorciatoie di ieri
di euristiche li mettiamo poi in atto
anche in in un contesto del genere solo
che nel momento in cui passiamo
dal complesso al semplice possiamo
commettere degli errori
qui ho proprio citato un famoso scultore
constantin bronx che dice la semplicità
è una complessità risolta
vediamo però cosa accade nel momento in
cui attuando questi meccanismi
la nostra mente può trarci in inganno è
uno dei meccanismi cognitivi
fondamentali di cui parlerò è il
confirmation byas che potremmo tradurre
come byas di conferma il pregiudizio di
conferma cioè quella tendenza umana che
quindi appartiene a chiunque che a
chiunque che ci fa selezionare le
informazioni cercare le informazioni di
interpretarle in una maniera che è
coerente con il nostro sistema di
credenze quello che abbiamo ben radicato
quindi con la nostra col nostro insieme
di col nostro insieme di valori con la
nostra visione del mondo e il
confirmation myers insieme ad altri
meccanismi che hanno un ruolo nel
contagio sociale quindi nel modo in cui
ci si influenza gli uni con gli altri
sono elementi chiave per permetterci di
capire meglio il fenomeno della
disinformazione e anche
dell'informazione in particolare gli
occhi vi parlo della polarizzazione di
gruppo che è uno dei fenomeni più
interessanti punto di vista
dell'influenza sociale è il fenomeno che
si presenta quando individui che
condividono una stessa visione del mondo
quindi che hanno opinioni
tendenzialmente simili nel momento in
cui discutono rafforzano le proprie
opinioni alla fine giungeranno ad avere
un'opinione più estrema da quella da
quella da cui erano partiti e un altro
esperimento interessante l'esperimento
di solo monash del 1955 in cui
veniva chiesto ai partecipanti otto
partecipanti di cui in realtà uno
soltanto era il soggetto veniva chiesto
di indicare quale delle tre linee nella
carta di destra corrispondesse alla
linea sulla carta di sinistra ora nei
primi due round tutti i partecipanti
davano la risposta corretta che è quella
anche abbastanza ovvia nel terzo round
alcuni dei partecipanti che facevano
parte dell'esperimento cominciano invece
andare delle risposte sbagliate quindi a
scegliere una delle due linee quella più
corta quella più lunga in questo caso il
vero soggetto dell'esperimento poteva
cambiare la propria scelta
bene nei primi due round il tasso di
errore era di circa l'un per cento nel
terzo round di quasi il 37 per cento
quindi in realtà di fronte alla
pressione nel gruppo tendiamo ad
abbandonare le evidenze stesse dei
nostri dei nostri sensi ora la
combinazione di questi meccanismi con il
contesto iperconnesso dal quale sono
partite rende questo ambiente
particolarmente favorevole alla
diffusione dei fenomeni virali ai
digital wolf eyes
qui vi mostro una mappa che presente nel
global risk report del 2013 del world
economic forum
quindi in questa mappa vengono indicati
i maggiori rischi geo politici e
tecnologici e potete vedere che la
massey digital bees information è
praticamente al centro della
costellazione
questo perché la disinformazione
digitale di massa può essere
particolarmente pericolosa perché può
influenzare negativamente l'opinione
pubblica e può avere dei le influenze
negative nel mondo reale
io qui mi faccio alcuni esempi
il caso per esempio jaden fifteen che è
un'esercitazione militare che si è
tenuta negli stati uniti e che fu
percepita inizialmente su internet come
un tentativo un complotto di obama
imporre la legge marziale sugli stati
uniti
al punto che il governatore del texas
renga bush decise galla allertare la
guardia nazionale
nel caso invece della gola dopo la morte
di due persone per aver bevuto acqua
salata l'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità ha dovuto ribadire che tutte le
cure ipotetiche alternative che
circolavano online e circolavano anche
via whatsapp erano del tutto
inaffidabili e molto pericolose o ancora
il caso della delegazione del ds in
sudafrica per le inadeguate politiche
sanitarie ci sono stati più di 300.000
morti che potevano essere evitate per ds
ma sicuramente la forte presenza forte
presenza dei negazionisti ha esacerbato
questa situazione i negazionisti
sostengono che la cai russia inoffensivo
che i farmaci antiretrovirali causano la
malattia piuttosto che curarla quindi in
italia non siamo esenti
questa è una è una delle bufale che
diventata più virale in italia in cui si
parla di un ipotetico disegno di legge
presentato dal senatore ci renga per
finanziare dei fondi per i parlamentari
che fossero in crisi alla fine del loro
mandato
questa bufala insomma andata virale nel
testo sono presenti diverse imprecisioni
per esempio il numero totale dei
senatori and differente da quello
previsto dalla nostra costituzione
eppure il testo è andato virale ancora
oggi sulla pagina del senatur ci renga
ci sono insulti da parte di molti utenti
italiani nonostante il senatur ci venga
non esista e sia un personaggio di pura
fantasia e quindi quello che abbiamo
fatto noi come gruppo di ricerca è fatto
di cercare di analizzare questi fenomeni
che sono fenomeni sociali ma in maniera
quantitativa quindi utilizzando
strumenti che venissero
dalla computer science quindi
nell'informatica che dalla statistica e
quindi mettendo insieme diversi
strumenti per sfruttare tutte le tracce
digitali che gli utenti lasciano sui
sociali sui social media e in
particolare ci siamo occupati primo
luogo di studiare il ruolo del
pregiudizio di conferma
nei meccanismi nella diffusione delle
informazioni
quindi per la metodologia ne abbiamo
analizzato il comportamento di utenti in
due differenti e contrastanti narrative
la narrativa scientifica e la narrativa
pseudo scientifica abbiamo raccolto i
dati sia abbiamo raccolto 2 dataset di
fede diversi un dataset italiano con
circa un milione di utenti è andata a 7
equivalente per gli stati uniti con
circa 5 con 54 milioni di utenti
entrambi i dataset coprono un arco
temporale di cinque anni dal 2010 al
2014 e la prima osservazione il primo
risultato è stato che abbiamo provato
empiricamente l'esistenza delle
cosiddette eco chamber cosa sono le
coscienze sono nei gruppi delle bolle in
cui gli utenti con la stessa visione del
mondo si raggruppano e continuano a
discutere e rinforzare le proprie
opinioni
abbiamo visto che la diffusione delle
informazioni è guidata dal confirmation
buyers ed è guidata dall omofilia quindi
dalla tendenza di cercare individui
molto simili a noi e quindi gli utenti
tendono a formare questi gruppi
polarizzati e abbiamo poi studiato quale
fosse il sentimento degli utenti
coinvolti all'interno di questi gruppi
questi sono dati per il dataset italiano
e qui possiamo vedere che in generale la
tendenza degli utenti è negativa c'è il
sentimento medio dell'utente
nell'approccio social network è negativo
ma il dato interessante è che nel
momento in cui consideriamo gli utenti
polarizzati cioè gli utenti che
concentrano la maggior parte della loro
attività
una delle due categorie allora in questo
caso potete vedere che la negatività
aumenta cioè questi utenti tendono ad
essere ancora più negativi
e cosa succede quando utenti di tribù
diverse quindi di gruppi differenti e
contrastanti si incontrano allora primo
risultato è che in realtà si incontrano
molto poco quindi questa interazione non
avviene e a quanto rara però quando si
incontrano la discussione degenera
assolutamente non c'è alcun tipo di
dialogo e quindi vedete che il
sentimento medio al crescere del numero
di commenti del post quindi al crescere
da discussione sta degenerando
allora ci siamo chiesti nel momento in
cui cerco invece di far cambiare idea
alle persone cosa succede cioè i
tentativi di di banking quell'attività
liz bufala re le informazioni false
funziona oppure no è efficace questo
l'abbiamo studiato sui 54 milioni di
utenti americani quindi li abbiamo
raccolto oltre alle pagine che diffonde
informazioni scientifiche pseudo
scientifica una terza categoria quella
del di banking e qui il primo risultato
è che solitamente pochissimi utenti
nelle coach amber pseudo scientifica
interagisce con i contenuti lidi banking
cioè il maggior fruitore del contenuto
di di banking è il l'utente delle co
chamber scientifica cioè quello a cui
realtà il the banking non servirebbe è
però pochi utenti pochi poche centinaia
di migliaia su nove milioni di utenti
pochi utenti interagiscono con queste
informazioni e quindi cosa accade con
questi utenti riusciamo a convincerli
in realtà abbiamo proprio misurato il
cosiddetto back fire effect cioè
l'effetto di rinforzo in pratica questi
utenti dopo aver interagito con i
contenuti di di banking invece di
cambiare idea rafforzano la propria il
proprio coinvolgimento e la propria
adesione ed identità con le cuocendo
partenza quindi quella pseudo
scientifica quindi realtà il the banking
sembra non funzionare e in questi studi
hanno avuto impatto anche anche sui
media
la giornalista caitlin bb curava la
colonna del washington post ictus fake
una colonna dedicata appunto a des bains
care le notizie false della settimana e
dopo la pubblicazione preliminare dei
risultati di questi studi decise di
chiuderla proprio perché cominciava a
sentire che effettivamente non sembrava
esserci poi un riscontro effettivo e io
vorrei chiudere citando cassan stand che
è stato a capo sotto l'amministrazione
obama dell'office information regolati
affairs e sa stand citato ai nostri
lavori il suo articolo su blogger blu
ipotizzando che probabilmente la
soluzione migliore potrebbe essere
quella di promuovere la cultura di
umiltà e di apertura e quindi l'idea che
vorrei passarvi stasera e che
probabilmente dovremmo tutti cercare di
uscire dalle nostre coscienze
quindi sia gli scienziati a cercare di
scendere un po dal piedistallo e a
comunicare meglio con la gente e in
generale nel nostro piccolo quotidiano è
quindi quello di cui abbiamo bisogno e
anche di essere consapevoli dei limiti
cognitivi di cui siamo tutti al di cui
siamo tutti i soggetti e partendo quindi
da questa maggiore consapevolezza noi
come studiosi possiamo invece utilizzare
i dati associarle modelli e cercare di
capire qualcosa di più di tutto questo
spazio formativo particolarmente
complesso grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]